NIRDHAR KHAZANIE: And today
I have the distinct pleasure
of introducing Karsh Kale.
Welcome, Karsh, to Google.
KARSH KALE: Thank you
guys for having me.
[APPLAUSE]
NIRDHAR KHAZANIE: So Karsh, I
started playing tabla probably
when I was around 10 years old.
And I remember one of
our family friends--
his name is Pradeep
[? Bindhe-- ?]
he came to our hometown in
Greenville, North Carolina,
and then he sat down with us.
And one time, at dinner, he saw
some tabla, which were there
in the living room, and
then he pulled them out
and he asked my dad,
can you play tabla?
Or, can I play tabla?
And I said, no, I'm
only 10 years old.
So then he started playing.
And then, lo and
behold, he became
my guru, which
started off after,
like, a career with around
two years of me playing.
But then I gave it up.
And then I didn't even
think about how much love
and how much fascination
I have with tabla.
How did you actually start
learning to play tabla
and how did that life--
KARSH KALE: Well, I mean,
tabla was always in my house.
My father is very much into
Indian classical music and film
music and old Marathi folk music
and all that kind of stuff.
So since I was born, this
music was playing in my house.
And he actually had tablas
in the house since--
I think, since I was about
three or four years old.
So I always went over, and I had
a kind of natural inclination
to the instrument.
But I rebelled against it.
It was--
NIRDHAR KHAZANIE: How so?
KARSH KALE: Well, because
growing up in Long Island
in the early '80s, I was
probably the only Indian kid
in a school of about 2,000--
mostly Jewish kids.
And it was just not
something that I could
use as a part of my identity.
So I was-- I mean,
I was a drummer.
I started-- I was
playing a drum kit.
I was into heavy
metal and hard rock
and all that kind of stuff.
NIRDHAR KHAZANIE:
What kind of music
were you listening to back then?
KARSH KALE: Oh,
Rush, Led Zeppelin.
I mean, those were my
doorways into music.
It was definitely
Rush and Led Zeppelin.
And then, I mean, all
kinds of different stuff,
all kinds of progressive rock.
And it wasn't until my
dad kind of realized
that I was listening
to sophisticated music,
so he took me to see Zakir Bhai.
He took me to see Zakir Hussain
perform in Columbia University.
And that was the first
time I realized that you
can take this art form and--
because I witnessed it.
I witnessed this
guy come to New York
and take this classical
art form and turn it
into a rock concert.
And everybody left there--
I mean, this guy wasn't
just a classical musician.
He was a rock star.
NIRDHAR KHAZANIE:
Is that when you
knew that you could actually
make a career out of it?
Was that what inspired you?
KARSH KALE: I mean, I
was too young to think
about it as a career.
I just knew that this
was something that I--
all of a sudden, was
something I wanted
to make a part of my
identity as a human being.
I mean, I didn't
really understand
how that was going to play
out later on in my career,
but that was where I really
embraced tabla and embraced
the science of
tabla and embraced
what it had to offer to--
not just as a tabla player,
as a classical musician, but
to all the different forms
of music that I was involved in.
Because it was
informing everything.
So that was my doorway
into playing tabla.
And then, of course,
from there it
evolved into becoming
a serious student.
NIRDHAR KHAZANIE: I don't know
how many of you in the audience
have followed Karsh, but
I've been following him
since he first debuted
in around like 2001-ish
with the "Realize" album.
I remember distinctly, I was
in my freshman year of college
with my friend Rocky [INAUDIBLE]
and we were in his car
and he puts on this track.
And then, out of nowhere,
I fell in love with tabla
all over again.
And that, for me, was
when I knew that this is
a completely different sound.
You were doing things in music
that no one else had ever
done before.
It was more than just
special, it was an awakening
into a new movement.
Tell me a little bit
about the motivation
for this album, and kind of
like where your inspiration came
from for it.
KARSH KALE: Well,
the first album
is called "Realize"
for a reason.
"Realize" was actually
a line in a song
that I was working on with
a friend, which wound up
on the album called "Fabric" a
few years before the album came
out.
And the line in the song is
"1,001 designs intertwined.
Which one is mine?"
And then "realize."
So "Realize" was kind of the
culmination of everything
that I had done as a
musician, as an artist,
as an explorer of music.
And finally, finding
that laser-like
hole that I could send all
of that information through.
It really had to
do with identity.
It had to do with the
fact that, back then--
this was at a time where we
didn't have social media.
We didn't have
access to anything.
So everything that
we were hearing about
was all kind of legend.
You know, that in London,
this stuff is happening.
In San Francisco, this
kind of thing is happening.
So that became a
huge impetus to kind
get involved in
this movement that
was about defining a new
generation's identity,
where we didn't have-- we don't
come from India in that way.
We didn't-- I mean, Bollywood
didn't necessarily define who
we are.
Neither did the Desis
Bhangra parties that
were happening at the time.
NIRDHAR KHAZANIE: Sure.
KARSH KALE: So we needed
to create something else.
We needed to create a
safe space for people
to be able to come and express
who it is exactly who they are.
And that's what this
music was about.
And it wasn't just
about my music.
At that same time, there was
this whole movement going on
in London with Talvin
Singh and Nitin Sawhney,
and the Anokha Movement, and
Nasha, and Badmarsh & Shri.
And then there was a whole
movement happening here
in San Francisco.
And there was stuff happening
in New Delhi and in Tokyo,
and it all started
happening at the same time.
So we all found out that
we all thought for a moment
that we were the only
ones in the world doing
what we were doing.
And then we realized
that this was actually
something that was
happening, and we were just
part of a time period where
we needed to define something.
And I think what you
felt was probably
similar to what I felt when
I Zakir Bhai perform, which
was just that, yeah,
I mean, this is me.
This is not-- and that's
what I've learned, I think,
as an artist ever since
making that first album,
is that people--
when you make music,
you can be as specific
as you want to be
about your own story.
But it really only takes shape
when somebody else's mirror is
in front of them and it
reflects off of their own story,
when people feel like
this is who I am.
NIRDHAR KHAZANIE: Right.
So you perform
regularly with artists
of all different
backgrounds, specializing in
percussion, strings, choral,
different disciplines.
Last night, you played
at the SF Jazz Center.
Amazing performance
KARSH KALE: Thank you.
NIRDHAR KHAZANIE: I was there.
What kinds of emotion do
you draw from your audience
when you're playing?
KARSH KALE: I think--
I mean, I'm less drawing
from the audience,
and more trying
to paint pictures
that I think that the
audience will resonate with.
And it's always different.
Before coming to SF Jazz,
I did 12 dates in India
where I was doing a DJ tour.
NIRDHAR KHAZANIE:
And we're really
happy that you came all the
way to Google as part of that.
KARSH KALE: Yeah, part of me
is still in India right now.
So forgive this slight jet lag.
But-- sorry.
I lost my spot.
What was the last part
of the last question?
NIRDHAR KHAZANIE: Oh,
yeah, I was just saying,
how do you actually just draw
energy from the audience?
KARSH KALE: Oh, right.
NIRDHAR KHAZANIE: And then how
people are relating to you.
KARSH KALE: Yeah, I
mean, once again, I
mean, back to what I
was saying before, I
think it's really about--
and over the years--
I mean, when I made
the first album,
I was shooting in the dark.
I had no idea how people
were going to react.
It was overwhelming,
the reaction.
But what stayed after
the initial wave
was that people would--
and to this day, people
from all over the world,
they write to me about the
fact that the music played
a particular role, sometimes
at a very difficult time
in their lives, or at a
time where they needed
to get through
something, or it was
something that motivated them to
be able to reach another level.
And I realized that, for
me, that's the kind of music
that I listen to, as well.
I mean, music is medicine
at its most potent.
So what I really
try and focus on
is the fact that
people will dance
and people will get into stuff.
And people have come up to
me, and say, hey, man, that
was some sick beats, yo,
and all that kind of stuff.
But what really--
where I feel like I'm
successful as an artist
is when people come to me
and say that the music
resonated in a way
where it was transformative.
It really helped them
through something.
NIRDHAR KHAZANIE: I
know my wife, Rani,
she's very much so
indebted because she always
listened to your
music in med school
and it's what, pretty
much, got her through.
KARSH KALE: Oh, wow.
NIRDHAR KHAZANIE: So I think
she can relate to that.
If you had the
opportunity for one year
to go back in time and
study from one of the greats
that you haven't already worked
with so far, who would it be?
KARSH KALE: Peter Gabriel.
NIRDHAR KHAZANIE: OK.
KARSH KALE: Yeah.
He's just somebody who--
I mean, not just Peter
Gabriel, but I've always
been fascinated by
artists who were
willing to change the
terrain, who were willing to--
whatever path was
in front of them,
they decided to
go into the forest
and completely change the
perception of what music was.
Someone like Peter
Gabriel, I mean,
he was quite instrumental
in introducing the world
to what we call world music.
NIRDHAR KHAZANIE: Yeah.
Any particular
track of his that--
KARSH KALE: Oh,
god, albums, albums.
I mean, everything
from "Genesis"
all the way to when he went solo
and to "The Passion" soundtrack
to all of his solo albums.
No, he's just somebody who is--
he doesn't think in terms
of a conventional format.
When we make--
If you're making
a rock song, you
want to have drums
and bass and guitar,
and maybe some
keyboards and vocals.
But someone like
Peter Gabriel will
get L. Shankar to
play electric violin
and have Youssou N'Dour
sing this one little line
at the end of the song.
And create a-- I
mean, the ornaments
on the tree that he
creates are so unique.
And so that's-- these are the
kind of people that I grew up.
I mean, still,
these are the people
that I look to as inspirations.
I mean, Zakir Bhai
is another one.
NIRDHAR KHAZANIE: Sure.
KARSH KALE: Bill
Laswell is another one.
Sting is another one.
I mean, these are people
who, when they make music,
they think so outside of the box
that I think that when they're
doing it, they're probably
a little scared, as well,
in terms of, I don't know
how this is going to land.
But usually, they
land on their feet.
NIRDHAR KHAZANIE: What's
your message to all
the young and upcoming artists?
I think this is something that
you're very passionate about.
You try to be
extremely proactive.
How do you suggest
that they actually
try to navigate the waters in
this very competitive music
environment?
KARSH KALE: I think it's--
especially nowadays
because we are so
inundated with so
much information
and you just go
on YouTube, and--
anything that
you're looking for,
you'll find 16 hours
worth of content.
That I think that what
oftentimes happens
is that we, as artists--
or not just artists, but
especially young artists--
tend to want to fit into
a mold and fit into a box,
or fit into a already tried and
true path that's been created,
whether it be Indian classical
music or techno or punk or rock
music-- whatever it is--
so that they can immediately
say, this is what I do.
And I think that those who--
I mean, the people
that I've seen
who have been able to
create a lasting career
are the people that
create something
that no one's necessarily
heard of before,
something outside of a
genre, something outside
of a particular box.
I think that what--
I always, when I meet young
artists who come to me and say,
you know, I've been
listening to your music
and if I listen to it
and it sounds like me,
the first thing that I say
is that I'm just waiting
for it to sound like you now.
You need to now find a
completely different space that
is yours.
Because the thing is that
there's so many different
places that an artist
can explore that resonate
with people.
This isn't foreign art.
We're not creating something
that people won't understand.
But it's about having
the courage to be
able to step out of that--
if you can find it on
YouTube, then create something
that you can't find yet.
That would be my advice
to any young artist,
is to try-- at least, that
should be your pursuit.
Because I think that, in
the end, where you wind up
is at a whole other space.
NIRDHAR KHAZANIE: That's
really good advice.
Technology is a huge part
of our daily lives today--
and you had talked about
this a little bit earlier--
especially for artists.
This is how you're
able to produce.
You're able to record different
thoughts and emotions, which
instantly can be
shared with the masses.
And I think YouTube
is a great way
of being able to distribute
that kind of content.
What do you think
that Google can
do more of to try to help
upcoming artists and people who
are thinking of trying
to share their music
and get out there more?
KARSH KALE: I think--
I mean, especially
for new artists,
I think when YouTube
first started,
it seemed a lot easier
to be able to find new--
because there wasn't as
much content available--
it was a lot easier
to find new content.
I think now, because there is
just so much stuff out there,
that it's very difficult
for a young artist
to be able to get heard, to
be able to find an audience.
And if there was,
maybe, a space where
people could go to only
for and strictly for brand
new presentations of
whatever it is, whether it
be in-studio presentations or
videos that young artists have
created or new tracks
or new artwork,
that there's a dedicated space
where people can actually
go to that they know
that this is all-- this
is brand new, fresh stuff.
And then, of course,
there's all the other stuff
that you can find, the
stuff that we've been
watching for years and years.
And now there's all the archival
stuff that we can get to.
But it winds up
getting so mixed up
that people don't realize
that this is brand new.
We don't ever hardly look at
the date, the upload date.
NIRDHAR KHAZANIE: Sure, no.
I think one of the nice things
is, for instance, if someone
wanted to learn even tabla
from the very beginning
part, the very early
stages now, you can go on
and you can ask for
something like tintal,
and then you can
go and there are
a hundred different
variations of how to do this.
KARSH KALE: Oh, yeah.
NIRDHAR KHAZANIE: And so
many different teachers
online who can
actually do that, too.
KARSH KALE: It's amazing.
I mean, I was
actually-- the other day
my daughter came home.
She's 15 now.
And she played me
some song, and she
was like, I want to
learn this on the piano.
I was a little busy at the time.
I was like, let's
do it on Sunday.
By the time Sunday
rolled around,
she had learned the song already
because she went on YouTube
and found a tutorial.
And she played it for me
and taught me the song.
NIRDHAR KHAZANIE: Wow.
That's amazing.
You've been in the industry
now, I'd say, what, at least--
KARSH KALE: About 25 years.
NIRDHAR KHAZANIE: 25 years.
How has technology changed
the music industry?
KARSH KALE: Oh, my god.
I've seen--
NIRDHAR KHAZANIE: Mainly
how people create pieces.
KARSH KALE: I've seen this,
especially in the music world.
I mean, when I was in
college, I was at NYU.
I was learning how to
record to 2-inch tape.
And we were cutting--
editing by cutting tape and
sticking it up on the wall
and figuring out
where the snare drum
hit so that we can cut
it at the right spot
so we can bring in another
part, or truncate one section.
And all of this stuff that
I spent years learning.
And then the year I
graduated, Pro Tools
was available in your bedroom.
So I hardly-- I don't think
I ever used it ever again.
So I mean, it was--
I mean, it's been--
I think every year
or two, technology
would just take a
leap forward, in terms
of what you're able to do.
I mean, I came from a time
where we needed to get together
with 16 musicians in a studio.
We'd spend three days recording.
And if you messed up,
you'd have to start again.
And editing was a big problem.
And then when it came
down to mixing a track,
there would be five of
us sitting at a board.
And we'd have to all sit
there, and kind of, oh,
got to get the
reverb at the bridge.
And if you miss it, you
have to start over again.
Whereas now, you can literally--
I mean, I have been
at the airport,
seen something inspiring,
worked on a track on my phone,
and landed and have made
a video for the track
that I made on my phone
and have put it up
on YouTube within five hours.
I mean, that's--
NIRDHAR KHAZANIE: That's
the power of distribution.
KARSH KALE: Well, it's just the
power of what's available now.
I mean, I think the only thing
that people need to balance
is the human element
and the experience
that one needs to
be able to have.
It's not enough to just
have the technology.
It's about marrying the two.
And if you're able to
actually get access
to that kind of knowledge,
to be able to help
be able to create
something on the spot
and be able to share it and
get feedback in the manner
that we're able to do right now.
That we also need
to be able to have
that library of information for
people to be able to access,
so that they can keep
going back and referencing
what it is that they're doing
and where they're drawing
their inspirations from.
NIRDHAR KHAZANIE: So let's move
into the VR aspect of things.
So you and I, we've been working
together for about eight months
or so now.
Do you want to share
with the audience
a little bit about our
VR experiment, what
we're working on?
KARSH KALE: Yeah.
NIRDHAR KHAZANIE: So for
those of you who may not know,
this is the Google VR jump rig.
It's a product that we
have here where we're
working with GoPro cameras.
The VR experience is
something that Karsh and I
are very passionate about.
So I'll give it to you to talk a
little bit about the motivation
behind what we're doing.
KARSH KALE: Yeah.
Well, I mean, I think for me--
I mean, even going back to my
childhood, what I've always
wanted to have is more
access to the artists
that I was listening to.
And back then, we had vinyls.
We had magazines.
Occasionally, we'd get to
see them on television,
and that was about it.
So I mean, I had videotapes
that I played a thousand times
and studied, just
to be able to get
into the intimate details of
what these artists were doing.
And even now, when my
daughter comes and asks me--
she's a musician, as well--
about a particular
musician, whether it
be someone like
Prince or David Bowie,
I always say to
her that you need
to spend the rest of your life
sitting in that genius's chair
and figuring out what it is that
they did, how it is that they
came about what they created.
And when the VR
world came about,
the first thing
that came to my mind
was, what an incredible way to
be able to give people access.
To let them step
into the studio,
to step into the
world of an artist,
and not just as a performer.
I mean, there's obviously
the performance aspect,
where people can actually
be there and sit right
next to the musician and watch
them and watch their hands
and watch their expressions and
try and get that vibe, and even
interact with them.
But there's also the aspect
of getting into the studio
and being in an environment
where you can actually
interact, where you can--
while in real time, there's
a track that's being created,
that's being manifested
right in front of you.
And then people leave the room.
And then you're able to actually
go in and play with that.
Have the kind of
unprecedented access
that we've never had
before with artists.
I mean, that was the
most inspiring thing
about the VR world that--
my initial inspiration.
And then, there's
the entire world
of how to change the whole
relationship between--
I mean, we're on a stage and
you guys are in the audience
right now.
But that this, we can change.
We can change this
whole interaction.
We can change the fact that
musicians are put on a pedestal
and the audience sits in
a place where you can only
have a certain level of access.
But if you can actually step on
stage and go behind the artist,
it just completely
changes your perspective.
And I think about when
I was seven years old
and I went to see Zakir Bhai,
if I could have went up on stage
and sat behind him while he
was performing and gotten
that kind of access, how
much information that
would have been for me.
It took me years to just
study whatever bits and pieces
that I could get.
And I realize that
for young artists,
for young students of music,
and just fans of music,
to be able to have that kind
of access, especially in a day
now where digital music has--
the one thing that
it's done is it's
also erased those artifacts that
we used to get from artists--
the liner notes,
the information,
the stuff they'd write
in albums and stuff.
The stuff that you'd-- the
little intimate details that
made you feel like you're a
little bit closer to the artist
have kind of disappeared.
So in that place, I feel
like we are stepping
into a whole other world where
we can give people really
incredible access to what it--
and not just for music.
I mean, this is for
anything, all walks.
NIRDHAR KHAZANIE: I'd
like to take this moment
and open it up for
audience questions.
If people have any
questions, we have mics.
AUDIENCE: What are the
challenges of effectively using
spatial audio in VR?
KARSH KALE: Well, I think
that that's something
that we're still exploring.
So I think that I'll have
to answer that question
in maybe a few months, in terms
of what the challenges might
be.
NIRDHAR KHAZANIE: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: How do you
address creative block?
I think every artist
experiences that.
What is your, I
guess, methodology
of getting over that hump?
KARSH KALE: Well,
I mean, for me,
if I get a creative block when
I'm working on my own stuff,
I just stop.
I just stop until--
I mean, for me, it doesn't
work unless I'm inspired.
And sometimes I'm inspired
at 3 o'clock in the morning.
I'll get straight
out of bed and I'll
go start working on something.
If I'm working on something for,
say, a film or something that
requires a deadline, I've
amassed enough skills
to be able to get it done.
But I think that the
difference is getting something
done that you know
will do the job,
and then there's
that inspired work
that you know only works
when you're inspired.
AUDIENCE: You play a
lot of instruments.
How did it work for you?
How do you learn all
those instruments?
How did you split your time
learning those instruments?
Was it one instrument for
a specific period of time
or how did it work?
KARSH KALE: Well, I mean,
when I was growing up,
I was a drummer.
So whenever I had
band rehearsals,
they were at my house.
So all of the musicians would
bring their instruments up
to my house and they
would leave them there.
So I had a house full of--
I had a bass and a
bass amp with pedals.
I had a guitar
with guitar pedals.
I had an 8-track
recorder and a keyboard.
And all of this stuff that
I never played myself,
but that's how I
learned how to play it.
And I learned also-- because
I had an 8-track recorder,
I started making my own music--
terrible music.
But it was my own stuff.
So I was learning how
to write bass lines.
And then how that
worked in counterpoint
to a keyboard part.
And how that worked
with a guitar part.
And then how that worked
with a particular drum part
that I was writing.
And so these were all--
that was the way for me to step
into that world of making music
on different instruments.
And I realized that my
fascination with music
was never only based
on one instrument.
When I would listen to--
when I was growing up
listening to Zeppelin
or Rush or Queen,
I was always listening
to really big music
with a lot of stuff going on.
And I always wanted to
be able to do all of it.
It wasn't about being
an expert or a virtuoso
at any of those
particular things.
These were means to be able
to create that large sound,
to be able to-- so that's why I
learned how to-- and I always--
I started playing sarod
for a little while.
I played santoor
And I knew that I wasn't going
to play these instruments
for the rest of my life.
But there was something
that I learned.
There was something that I was
able to-- that I still apply in
my own music by spending
that two years playing sarod
and those four years
playing santoor.
As a tabla player, as a
composer, all of these things
come into play.
And a lot of people,
a lot of musicians--
especially producers--
that you meet,
oftentimes, are people
who have been able
to explore a lot
of different styles of music
and different instrumentation.
It's important to know
the physicality of what
it is that you're working with.
So now when I work
with a guitar player,
I have a much
deeper understanding
of what it is that they're
doing besides me just
asking for something
and them delivering it.
I know what to ask for.
I know what their first
physical limitations are.
I know the limitations
of the instrument itself.
I'm not going to sit here
and do a guitar solo for you,
but I know enough
about the instrument
to be able to work with
great guitar players
and get more out of
that interaction.
AUDIENCE: For me, I feel
like your fusion music was
the first that connected
with me in a very
pure and specific way.
And yet, it's always
evolving and you're always
pushing the boundaries on it.
So where do you feel that
fusion music is today,
and where do you
think it's headed?
KARSH KALE: Well, I
think, fusion music
has always been happening.
That's what music is.
I mean, everything, even Indian
classical music is fusion.
It's a fusion of
many different ideas
that come together on one stage.
But these ideas come from
many different places.
So I think that it's
always evolving.
I mean, fusion is the process.
It's not a style.
It's not a particular
form of music.
Fusion is the process that
we acknowledge as music
is evolving in front of us.
And we might have had a moment
where this was our time.
This was the time where we
resonated most with that music.
But it's-- I think that what I
see and what's happening today
is another generation
of artists who are--
they are already fused.
They're growing up with U.
Srinivas and Zakir Hussain
and John Coltrane and
the latest heavy metal
album and the latest
Anderson Paak record
and whatever new hip hop
record is coming out,
all happening at the same time.
And they're expressing
that all at the same time.
I mean, some of
the artists that I
work with now in my
collective in India
are young artists who are
blowing my mind with how
they're able to come
and be like, oh, yeah,
it's this, this,
this, and that, right?
So it's kind of
like a techno meets
bhajan meets a light
classical thing
with a little Carnatic twist,
and a dash of heavy metal.
Whereas for us, it
took us years to be
able to kind of get to that
point where we understood.
So I think that, if
anything, that's, I think,
where we're at now.
It's that the music that we're
going to hear from now on
is going to be on a
whole other level.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Karsh.
KARSH KALE: Hi.
AUDIENCE: I'm a huge
fan of your work.
I would like to
ask you about taste
and if you, from
your own experience,
have any ideas on creating a
rich journey of discovering
new music?
KARSH KALE: Well, I mean,
that was what I was actually
addressing before.
I think that there
is still-- there
needs to be a little bit more
of a platform for new emerging
artists who have
something new to say.
Because oftentimes, it
gets lost in the mix.
There's so much stuff
out there that it's
hard to find the new stuff.
And I think that that
also has to do with--
it's also a curator's job to
bring those things together
and present new music
in that particular way.
And I think there are people
out there-- people who
are doing podcasts and people
who are putting together
playlists-- that a lot
of people check out
because they trust what it is.
I mean, I remember
when I was coming up,
back then, it was
people's radio shows.
But there were a
few people who were
responsible for introducing
the world to some of the--
I remember when my
second album had come out
and Coldplay was
still a new band
that was being
introduced as a brand
new artist in this compilation
that I was a part of.
Now they're, of course,
one of the biggest
bands on the planet.
But yeah, it was because there
was a platform like that.
So I think that the important
thing is to be able to have,
and encourage people, as
well, to share playlists
and to share-- to curate--
these kind of things
where people have access
to new music and new artists.
AUDIENCE: So one
thing I want to know,
because you've been in
the industry for a while
and you have worked
various artists
from India or from elsewhere.
How do they approach the music?
I mean, what's the
difference in their approach
to the music, which is--
the Asian underground is still
based on Indian classical,
to an extent.
So how do they
approach the music
based on their
cultural background?
KARSH KALE: I mean,
I can't really
say that there's a particular--
I mean, every
musician is different.
I've met artists that
are purists coming
from the electronic music
world that don't really
necessarily understand
how to step out
of that particular box.
I've met Indian
classical musicians
who've been playing
for decades who
have absolutely no issue
with hearing some grimy drum
and bass track and know
exactly how it is that they
fit into that context.
So there's no real
answer to that.
I mean, it really comes down
to the individual artists.
I mean, there have been
classical musicians
who I've worked with that
I've had to completely mute
everything that I was working on
and just play a classical tabla
part just so that they could
understand what the context was
that I was trying
to bring them into.
And usually, those are
actually younger artists.
Older artists tend to
be a little bit more
versatile because they've
been there and done that.
We assume when we hear
musicians that this
is what they do so this is
the bubble that they live in.
But they hear everything.
They've seen everything.
And the older the artist--
I mean, someone like Zakir
Bhai, who's not only seen,
but he's lived
through, he's breathed
through so many
different genres of music
that his own audiences
still have no idea how much
this guy has lived through.
So when a guy like that
comes into the studio,
I'm hard-pressed to throw
him a curveball where
he's scratching his head.
NIRDHAR KHAZANIE: Well, thanks
everyone for your questions.
So we have a very nice surprise.
It's that Karsh,
I think, is going
to give us a quick little
demonstration of the tabla.
KARSH KALE: So for those of you
who have not seen these drums,
it's called the tabla.
Traditionally, an Indian
classical instrument,
but now used all
over the world in all
walks of music, whether it be
in Hollywood films or hip hop
music or pop music or Kirtan--
all kinds of stuff.
And it's also an incredibly
versatile instrument
in that it's not only
a rhythm instrument,
it's also a tonal instrument,
a melodic instrument.
And it's a a talking
drum, as well.
It can speak.
It can have conversations.
So the way that--
the repertoire that we
learn is based on syllables.
These are syllables
that we turn into words.
Then these words, we
turn into paragraphs,
and we create stories.
There is a particular
rhythm called Keherwa,
which is probably one of
the most popular rhythms
all over the planet.
And you hear it in
devotional music.
You hear it in Bhangra.
You hear it in Bollywood.
You hear it in reggae music.
You hear it in all kinds
of different music.
And it's a very simple rhythm
that anyone can learn, and then
expand upon.
So the syllables
of Keherwa are--
[DRUM SOUNDS]
dhin, naa.
So it's dhin naa,
dhin, dhin naa.
Dhin naa, dhin, dhin naa.
So dhin--
[DRUM SOUNDS]
So that's the general
composition of Keherwa.
But there's many, many different
interpretations of that.
So I'll kind of take you
through a little bit of that.
[TABLA MUSIC]
[APPLAUSE]
It was kind of like
typing with a typewriter.
I had to keep moving it back.
But thank you.
NIRDHAR KHAZANIE:
Thank you, everyone.
[APPLAUSE]